what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and a
few days ago they released the official
script for spider-man no way home if
you're interested in reading the script
i suggest you do it because it has a lot
of very interesting things that are said
in the script that aren't said in the
movie there's a lot of subtext that we
don't see in the movie but is implied
just like i talked about yesterday one
of the final scenes with mj says that
she has a sense or feeling of
recognition when peter leaves so the
script is pretty revealing it is a long
read it's about 185 pages i think but
worth it and i noticed something about
the very last line the very last page of
the script that made me
really sad actually i read a line that
hit me pretty hard a line that's not in
the movie it's just a descriptive line
about peter parker
spider-man and this line kind of makes
you feel like peter parker died so i
want to talk about this line i want to
read it to you and then talk about how
it can be redeemed and revived in future
movies because we know now that tom
holland is coming back for more
spider-man films so be sure to subscribe
to stay up to date on spider-man and the
mcu so this is literally the last line
of the script and of the film and like i
said it hit me rather hard it's right
after spider-man makes his brand new red
and blue spider-man suit and he jumps
out his window and he goes and soars
over rockefeller center and this is what
it says about the final scene soars over
the rockefeller christmas tree with a
newfound sense of freedom liberated from
having to juggle two lives now of course
this part is really nice it's uplifting
it's really great to hear but at the
same time that is the struggle that
spider-man ultimately always has to deal
with it's kind of who he is but it is
nice to see him not really have to
struggle with that for the moment but
then we get to the next line and this is
the line that really hit me peter parker
is no more but spider-man lives on dot
dot dot
fade out
peter parker is no more that line really
hit me because that is essentially what
happened peter parker's existence was
erased everybody that he knew and loved
they have no idea who he is anymore
everything that they went through with
him never actually happened now it did
but not to them so essentially
everything that peter kind of went
through in his life before spider-man
and all the good things that he went
through even when he was spider-man but
as peter parker essentially didn't
happen for him either which is really
really sad now of course they help
shaped him and he will always have the
memories of aunt may and happy and ned
and of course mj but the sad thing is is
he can't go back to any of that because
again peter parker is no more and it's
honestly really really sad but the good
news is is of course there is redemption
for this and there is a revival that
could happen as i mentioned marvel
studios president kevin feige along with
sony executive producer amy pasquale did
confirm that they are already working on
a new spider-man film this will be a
film with tom holland so peter parker
will return yes nobody knows who he is
right now and yes it's just spider-man
right now but we did see that ged book
in his apartment at the end of no way
home which means he is going to attempt
to go to college so peter parker will
return it's almost like they should have
put that at the very end when it says
like the avengers will return they
almost should have said peter parker
will return and maybe everybody will
eventually remember who he is maybe
he'll get his happy ending with mj and
his best friend will be back ned but
right now unfortunately it's kind of sad
that peter parker is no more he let his
love go he let his best friend go aunt
may is gone happy has no idea who he is
tony stark's gone and now essentially
peter parker is gone and it's really sad
but i'm really excited to see what
marvel has in store for us for the
future of spider-man but let me know
what you think in the comments down
below did this hit you like it hit me
let me know don't forget to subscribe
and like the video and of course for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof